Hey, Kim.
Alright, how are you?
Good, how's it going?
Playing Crape.
How about you?
It's good to hear. Things are going pretty good. Working from home today, it's been a little bit busy at the office, a little crazy. So it's a good day so far.
Great, great, and how are the engineers doing? So, with Seattle and Abe?
They're doing good. So as you know, Amit is out and about. He's taking a little bit of leave, which is good. Some time to relax and recoup a little bit. So it's good to hear. So it's been really stepping up for me and doing a really great job. I just recently talked to him about some new opportunities. So
Yeah.
Excited for that. And then she is great as usual. Definitely doing her thing. You know, triage and dispatch has still been very smooth lately.
Yeah, and I also heard that you assigned some trainings to them.
Yeah, absolutely.
On issue, OK.
Yeah, you know, so we are moving forward with a few things. So we have an initiative to start using this tool called Terraform.
Right.
So it's an infrastructure tool. I don't know if you're familiar with it, but it is like infrastructure code. So it's a repeatable documented process. ProKidney, our biggest client, is going to start utilizing that for creation of their Azure environment, but we're...
Probably going to start using it as a standard practice at Info Pathways. It looks like it's a great way forward for scalability.
Exactly, yes.
Thank you.
Yeah, so...
and a good opportunity for them to learn as well.
Yeah, so we, I'll be honest, Info Pathways is new to this tool. I wanted to see if Aman and Suhrid maybe had a little bit of experience and Suhrid said that he had taken a little bit of learning in regards to that, but he would need a refresher, which is totally fine.
It's new to a lot of the members in, you know, Maryland and even in North Carolina, but we are having roughly like 8 or 9 people involved in the training of this so that we can start using it, you know, across all environments.
So that's going good. Yep. So that's one of the big things. And then honestly, there's another, there's this software called SAS that seems to be used by multiple environments. So it's SAS and they are.
Okay.
Great.
Yeah.
in a partnership with us, where they go out and they sell, you know, SAS, and then we're eventually going to start supporting that. So that's going to be a big part of our business model. So we actually have five members in Texas right now attending on, you know, really understanding the tool.
Mhm.
And it sounds like, sounds like it's going to be pretty big from what I've heard. It sounds like, you know, they've already made some contacts. And with that, you know, we're really going to want to start supporting that. So some exciting news. We're going to get big, I think, soon.
Next.
Yeah, really, really great to hear that we are growing and expanding, so...
It's really great.
Yeah, you know, and the engineers have been a great part of that too. You know, we've got a lot of operational praise and I'd like to give you that feedback that things are running very smooth and Tom and Teresa are very happy with the engineers' performance and
Yeah.
Overall company happiness. We've done a second round evaluation with the team in HR. And people are really happy lately, which is really great to hear too. So hopefully that's replicated in the team there. But yeah, we're running a pretty smooth ship right now.
That's really good to hear, yeah.
Good news.
Yeah. So like I said, I want you to know you guys are doing a great job. And we appreciate you guys.
Thank you so much, Brian. And yeah.
Really feeling happy to hear all these growth, expansion, good feedback. Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
We really appreciate your support and help.
So.
You know, no problem. Like I said, we're here to work together, and I think we've got a great relationship going.
Yes.
Yeah.
And regarding the cadence, the monthly cadence, so Ryan, you feel free whenever you feel like you cannot join or you want to skip the that month that month cadence, you can ping me on the teams, you can email me. So that's not a problem. Absolutely fine.
Okay. Yeah, the only reason I had mentioned it is just because, again, we've had pretty good feedback from the team, and I feel like things are running really good. And honestly, that can hopefully free you up a little bit more. I mean, you guys obviously have your day-to-day with the engineers. You guys are working with them consistently, but as far as
Mhm.
you know, involvement. I think a monthly touch point is still really great. You know, if we have new initiatives or anything that's coming up that, you know, we really want to involve you guys to keep you up to date. Like in this instance, the SAS and trying to figure out Terraform is really great, but.
You know, I think I think we're looking for, you know, how do we keep growing the business? I'm going to probably be stepping into a slightly different role moving forward. They're trying to open up my capacity. And, you know, I really think that we're going to really start booming here soon. So.
Mhm.
Yep.
With that, you know, I, I think, uh, I think things are going good.
Great, great.
So with that being said, let's quickly jump into the presentation deck and let's quickly review their performance for the last five weeks.
Okay.
It'll be great.
Yeah, no problem.
Okay, so once again, welcome to our monthly business review. This is from March 16th till April 17th.
No change in the agenda. Agenda is same. Check in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
There are a few highlights. We have been receiving positive feedback from Amit, Suhrid and Sia. Even the end users he said that he shared was great for them. Sia is becoming more independent. And Aman was acknowledged for his strong SOP understanding and documentation process. Security ownership.
We discussed about some upcoming opportunities, and you also requested to gain some deeper involvement. And he is working on that. Additional projects we also discussed, including server migrations and SharePoint. And also we discussed about some network opportunities.
And then we have the planned video for Amit. He will be back on May 5th. And thank you for sharing the CX for the month of March for all three engineers.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So, moving on to the action tracker, both Aamir and Suhrid, they have been working on their level up. So, yeah, we they are targeting it to complete by the end of May. That is still in progress.
Okay.
So these are the KPIs we discussed earlier, and I also shared the KPIs for Sia on the email. So whenever you get time, so please review them and see if we can also track them through the dashboard.
Good.
Absolutely, yeah, and I just need to settle down, get some time. It's been a little bit crazy, but in a good way.
Yeah.
I understand, that's fine.
No problem.
And let's jump into the performance analysis. This is Amad's utilization for those five weeks. Pretty consistent, moving around 73 to 81 percent. That makes his average utilization 71 percent.
And yeah, so he's primarily working on the end user tickets, disk space alerts, Wintel, hacker directory.
This is his ticket data. He vote on 235 tickets in those five weeks and close 200 of them. That makes his ticket closure at 85%.
And we have seen an increase in the ticket closure based on our last connect. And in our last connect, it was around 82%, so it is now 85.
Excellent.
Yeah, and I think things are going really good with him.
Yeah. And moving on to Sarbjeet, again, his utilization, I mean, being in off hours, so his utilization is a little low as compared to Amit, but still, that's justifiable. So he is, his average utilization is above.
70% for three weeks.
Yeah.
really helpful. I don't know if they told you, sounds like you guys also dealt with the spoofing emails these past few weeks. So he has been a critical part in resolving those issues and really working to update like DMARC. So.
Yes.
You know, even stuff like that we've been getting him more involved in and he's done a really good job. Like I said, I want to give a huge shout out to him too.
Yeah.
Okay, moving on to his tickets data, he booked on 335 tickets and close to 20 of them. Ticket closure again on the lower side, but that's still because of an off-hour support. His ticket closure was at 66%.
But still looks good. Cool.
Yeah, and moving on to way forward, they are working on their level ups as already discussed and will continue to support.
I will then serve it to meet your KPI targets.
All right, that looks good.
And here comes the Build It Live for 2026. So we have a session in August 3rd, 4th, and 5th from 9 A.m. to 5 P.m. in New Jersey City.
So...
You can scan this code for more information. I will share the details with you. So any availability during that time.
Maybe you or from someone from your team can join this session.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely. I know last year me and Thomas went. I'd like to try and attend again. I think we gained a whole lot of traction as far as, you know, how to better our team. You know, we're really moving the team forward these last few months, and I think some of your guys' coaching and, you know, information that we learned there was really pivotal.
So yeah, I would love to join you guys again. Let me just talk with my team about it.
Sure, I will.
Ask someone from the CX team to reach out to you and share the details so that you can have the full agenda. We can have the agenda by tomorrow.
and we'll share the details on the email with you.
Okay, sounds good.
We can go from there. Okay, and here comes the AI by design. So here are some services that we share, and this is the team GPS. You are already using it.
Yeah, yeah, we're loving that tool, by the way. Things are going really good.
And...
Yeah.
Yep, right. So that's it. Any question, any feedback you have, any idea of improvement you think we can work on?
Um...
I can't really say for the engineers that there's any real improvement that needs to happen. I think the only thing for Sia, I know that she's been taking independence and that's been going really well. There's only one small thing that we want to try and work on and it's maybe slowing down to read through tickets.
just to analyze if they're supposed to be, because we have kind of a complex, like, you know, new implementation versus new help desk, and then we have managed service versus TS clients. As an initiative for triage and dispatch, we would just like for them to try and analyze.
If it's a managed service client versus a technical service client, just because that ends up being billable, we usually catch it by the time it goes to like billing. But if triage and dispatch can do that a little bit sooner, that's always going to benefit us. And we have like a document in it's like an Excel sheet called schedules.
Mhm.
Okay.
where the clients are built out as managed service versus technical services. But that's something that as a whole, Trout and Dispatch are working on. Not that it's like a bad thing. Like I said, everything is going very, very well. That's the only real thing for maybe her to try and.
work towards. And then I guess if I am to bring back up just what we initially talked about, Terraform and SAS becoming such a huge part of our business. If there is any formal training that they already have.
Yeah.
just kind of revisiting that would be helpful. We are also getting some training on this, just because it is, again, involving most of our engineers. So, yeah, that would be the only other thing. But not really like.
So, sure, I will I will check if our learning portal has any trainings on Terraform. So, I will definitely get evidence. So, we enrolled for the same.
Just for the refresher.
All right, awesome. Yeah, but overall, like I said, these are just things to help with our initiatives. It's not any, not any like complaints or anything bad. Things are, things are pretty great.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely. Thank you, Brian, for sharing the feedback and honest feedback. So, and really appreciate you joining these calls and talking to us and sharing the feedback for the engineers. So,
Yeah, no problem. That's why I said it's good to talk with you for sure.
Yeah. Thank you, Ryan. And yeah, so as I said earlier, so in case you, whenever you think like you can skip the cadence, you're busy or doing some work, you're getting up working on the expansion and growth. So we can definitely skip that call or reschedule or whatever you feel like.
That's not a problem for us. That is completely understandable.
Okay.
Yeah, I appreciate that. Appreciate you guys understanding.
And thank you, Ryan, for joining this call today, and that's all we have for today. So thank you.
All right, cool. Well, thank you again, Kip. I hope you have a good day and we'll connect a little bit later.
Yep, yep, sure. Thank you. Bye-bye.
Great, thanks, buddy. Bye.